et is one of the most critically beloved
and commercially successful films of all
time with a lifetime worldwide
box-office of almost 800 million ET
could probably still get a sequel
greenlit in seconds so why didn't u n--
averse or phone home to see if they
could get the little guy back for a
second adventure he is y et tu nocturnal
fears never happened
stuck at the starting line ET
screenwriter Melissa Mathison struck up
a creative relationship of director
Steven Spielberg while she was dating
Harrison Ford during filming for Raiders
of the Lost Ark according to producer
Kathleen Kennedy Spielberg was already a
fan of her work on the black stallion
and after they hit it off Matheson got
the gig for eating over 700 million
dollars in box office returns later
Spielberg wanted to see if she can make
lightning strike twice of a follow-up
but the outline they sketched together
was never anything more than a tentative
stabber a sequel a writer and director
sitting down to bang out a nine page
treatment for an idea isn't anywhere
close to free production it got very
dark
if 82 had followed the treatment written
by Spielberg and Matheson the film would
have shown a group of aliens descending
to earth in response to the distress
call from Zurich which turns out to be e
t--'s real name cool more little e t--'s
right not really these albino mutations
would have red eyes and razor-sharp
teeth kind of like et's evil neighbors
or second cousins or something they
spend some time in the woods mutilating
cattle and capturing animals in light
cages before elliot Gertie and their
friends show up mistakenly thinking et
is back the kids are interrogated and
Elliot is tortured into in consciousness
while crying for et to save him sounds
like the perfect follow-up to a
family-friendly classic huh the
treatment has a happy ending and it's
obviously just a small part of a longer
more detailed story but still turning et
even partially into a horror movie seems
like a stretch not to mention the
Hershey Company would probably not be
too thrilled to see Reese's Pieces being
associated with sadistic intergalactic
torturers Spielberg's first sequel
Steven Spielberg famously hated the idea
of sequels for a long time having
declined universals request for another
Jaws film four years before they finally
made one anyway without him his
treatment for
t-too nocturnal fears was supposedly
drafted just days after the original
arrived in theaters and might have been
little more than the byproduct of the
initial excitement Spielberg eventually
came around to the ideas of sequels when
he filmed Indiana Jones and the Temple
of Doom three years later but it should
be pointed out that he's only ever done
four sequels throughout his career and
they've been for two of the biggest
movie franchises of all time Indiana
Jones and Jurassic Park this is a guy
who chooses his project wisely and the
story of eats his sadistic relatives
clearly didn't fit into his artistic
vision one-and-done
et is a timeless classic and a fully
realized story with likable characters
great visual effects on above all a
feel-good resolution about friendship
and love that audiences of all kinds can
appreciate Spielberg said it himself in
an interview of Empire magazine in 2009
et is a closed story it had a beginning
middle and a definite ending and we had
nowhere to take it except to go home
with him know that I want to bring him
back to earth for a second time ET isn't
an action hero who's only just shown us
the beginning of what he can do making
an ET sequel would have been akin to
making It's a Wonderful Life to which
also almost happened thanks Hollywood
Spielberg pulled the plug in a speech to
the American Film Institute Spielberg
said I think a sequel to ET would do
nothing but Rob the original of its
virginity people only remember the
latest episode or the pilot tarnishes
which is quite a reverential way to talk
about a movie featuring a cross-dressing
candy binging alien who communicates
through a Speak & Spell but it also begs
the question when did he change his mind
and why didn't he give George Lucas as
memo decades ago
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know if you like to
see a sequel to eating